the big problem that I see especially
with the right in this country is
capitulation every step of the way the
reasonableness the desire to be
reasonable and not engaged you're
playing a game of Monopoly you're
watching the dude you're playing against
pull bills out of the bank and you go
hey man you're cheating and they go no
I'm allowed to do it and you go okay
and then you lose you go man how did I
lose that's what they're doing it's also
as lawyers too that are probably because
I guarantee you Trump is probably like
well you know what no I don't want to
show but it's allergies on them hey man
you got to show up like let's just get
this done let's do this peacefully Etc
so that you can keep campaigning and so
what happens is every day a grain of
sand is added to the Heap yeah and as
the a better analogy is frogs in a pot
boiling
as the temperature increases by one
degree every day the frogs isn't
actually not a true soy frogs do notice
but the analogy as it goes if you if you
put frogs in a Boiling Pot they jump out
if you put them in water and slowly turn
the temperature up they just boil to
death